so some people have requested that I
review this trailer I saw this trailer
to a movie called looper and I was like
it could either be crap or cool it's a
sci-fi movie coming out in September
which probably means crap but whenever
the coolness of a movies teetering on
the edge like that that's worth talking
about or so the movie looper stars
Joseph gordon-levitt and Bruce Willis
and the premise is this time-travel has
been invented in the future Joseph
gordon-levitt if someone called a looper
so when criminal organizations in the
future needs someone God is happened
back to me and I eliminate the target
from the future one thing about this
though I got to think to myself wait a
minute time travel is a thing in the
future and that's how they use it do
they use it in any other way possible
like making important people disappear
it's just people that cross the mob you
need time travel to make people
disappear the mob and governments have
been doing it for years all you need to
shovel a desert and very little
imagination
what about brick top's big firms that
not work anymore there are no pig farms
in the future it's pretty smart when I
heard about it as brick taps use time
travel now I don't think so I don't know
maybe they'll explain that in the movie
right now I'm just like that's just all
you're doing with it but aside from
picking the movie apart that's clearly
not out yet the cool part comes when
Joseph gordon-levitt gets someone he's
supposed to kill and it's Bruce Willis
never lay your target escape even if you
target its you all right that might be
interesting so Levitz going after Bruce
Willis Bruce Willis is going after I
don't know someone maybe he's just
trying to survive then the mobs going
after Joseph gordon-levitt and you have
yourself what might be a pretty cool
movie you see what I mean there you see
this trailer and you're like that could
be really cool but this looks like the
kind of movie that I've said that to
myself before you know that could be
cool and it turned out not
I'll tell you what if I had time travel
I'd be like okay let's go back to the
90s I'll just show up in the 90s you'd
be like ok people
all right this internet thing it's
really cool but I got one word for you
Google let's make it happen you will be
ruling the world by December 21st the
year of our Lord 2012 otherwise known as
the day of the zombie apocalypse has
probably come and thanks Mayan so this
movie looks like it could be cool I hope
they play up the aspect of Joseph
gordon-levitt and Bruce Willis being the
same person that could be really cool
which makes me think wait a minute this
Bruce Willis know everything that Joseph
gordon-levitt's gonna do because he
remembers doing it when he was Joseph
gordon-levitt's age just a time-travel
crap surprise your brain I can hang well
you said it buddy I think it would be a
logical thing to touch on that and play
that up and it does look like in the
trailer Bruce Willis does remember doing
Joseph gordon-levitt's work and trying
to kill him because he has the bars of
gold on his back or whatever that
deflects the gunshot I just can't help
but think I'm gonna walk out of this
movie going alright there are a lot of
holes in this movie
it's not nice to get in touch with me
because I will save them on some
payrolls don't pay Joseph gordon-levitt
for anything you do one thing and one
thing only send them to the end of time
hang out in the training room hopefully
they don't touch the bucket otherwise
they might just screw up everything and
kill chrono and their crew and then La
Voz will take everyone out in the year
1999 I write crap all right maybe the
Levitt things better so if you guys
could do time travel what would you do
with it comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more